this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one finance app on the App Store what
you might not know is that you can also
put cash up in your wallet with the cash
card
it's got boosts it's got great safety
features there's no credit check needed
to get one so that's good you know you
don't need to get a credit check to get
this it just works immediately so talk
about this more later on the show but
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market what's
up guys how you doing how was your
Halloween man how was your Halloween how
was all the [ __ ] you guys dress up what
you do it's all a lot of people going up
as The Incredibles family a lot of
people went has what are they called the
minions a lot of family costumes I saw
saw Kevin Hart dress up like minions and
takes 75 professional photos where does
that guy find the time what he does so
much work and then also does a photo
shoot with his family I think there
might be two or three Kevin Hart's
that's amazing I mean just god bless
like my grandmother would like my
great-grandmother would say like my
grandmother would say god bless
so yeah I'm on my app live they catch my
my my podcast before anybody else so if
you want to do that catch the podcast on
the app I've been in town now for about
two weeks
let me go over some dates there I got
Miami that's sold out West Palm Beach
that's sold out two shows and then I
have Jacksonville and I think that there
might be some tickets left in
Jacksonville on Friday night and the
reason why that's not sold out is
because it's Jacksonville and yeah it's
swamp infested and so then after that it
is Atlanta and one show sold out and
there's a Late Show that I believe sold
does not sold out I believe there's
still tickets left in Atlanta if you
want to go and also I put Chicago on
sale last like three days ago and it's
gone dude
so Thank You Chicago 3,500 seats gone in
like a day it was like a day and a half
it all went I didn't realize how strong
the cult was in Chicago but let me tell
you something it's cold and when I get
there in February I'm bringing my
jackets and we're all bundling up I want
people to start wearing all white to my
shows like it's a real cult that's what
I want I want all white now careful
don't wear a white pointy hat don't even
wear a hat because we don't want that to
get confused speaking of which I was I
was at coffee earlier today and I
experienced actual not to me but I
experienced racism in the in the in what
he called the public in the in the
actual oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up I'm here in
the hold on let me fix this I
experienced racism actual racism for
like there were these five white people
at the coffee place and then they were
talking Hollywood [ __ ] and you could
tell that it was not real in Hollywood
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on
people think they're producers people
pretend they're producers people do it
to get laid people do it to seem
powerful people do it to seem like they
got [ __ ] going on a lot of girls do it
because they want people to know that
they're not just a pretty face a lot of
guys do it because they were beat up in
[ __ ] middle school right so so these
there were three guys two girls
bullshitting at the [ __ ] Coffee Bean
and Tea Leaf and they were all white and
then there was another table that wasn't
with them that
was a black guy just kind of hanging out
and they were talking about movies loud
the guy was on the phone and he was like
yeah what I like to do is I like to
spend more to get more that's what I
like to do that's what he did so what
you knew immediately was that guy's full
of [ __ ] or as my cousin would have said
when he was younger after her my grandma
said [ __ ] and then my grandma said
no no don't say that my grandma said oh
you're full of [ __ ]
she said take your diaper off we got to
wipe your ass and my cousin was like no
and she was it oh you're full of [ __ ]
he's gonna flush [ __ ] and then me and my
brother laughed so hard and then he
started kept on saying [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyway so he he was full of [ __ ] he was
saying stuff like you know what we we
offered him 750 if we got off from a
little more than we got off from a
little more like by the way he was in
[ __ ] like just a he just he couldn't
look less like a producer he was did he
just looked like some guy hey some guy
you're not making a movie okay you know
so so now he's talking his [ __ ] and
this other by the way I oversaw this
other lady that was next to him doing do
you know in the meeting and she was
texting the longest text don't text the
longest text especially in a meeting
like these people were just all full of
[ __ ] one guy had a broken arm literally
you know broken arm like like it was
like the cover of a [ __ ] Spanish
textbook because they're trying to make
it politically correct so you know what
I mean though about that how Spanish
textbook they always had like on the
cover they were by the way Spanish
textbooks were so ahead of their time in
PC culture if you look at any [ __ ]
old Spanish textbook from high school
there was always like a white guy a
black eye an asian girl and then always
a guy in a wheelchair you couldn't flip
three pages without seeing a [ __ ] guy
in a wheelchair they were always down
with the like paraplegic Spanish type
book textbooks because they always
wanted to and I feel like part of it was
because they one of the things that they
tried to drive home drive home was I
always remember see yesterday relieved
that I think that means wheelchair
see yesterday Louisa say he's a
wheelchair in Spanish seekest de Rueda
dude that's how we would learn and then
I get the Omega dude when they would do
see God they ruin us that's what it is
see ya they ruin us
and every time you had [ __ ] they'd be
like oh my god dude we would listen to
this [ __ ] what do you call him audio
tapes and we'd be they would say it
they'd be like wheelchair see ya
they'd be like wheelchair oh yeah that's
what it'll be like it'd be like
wheelchair like a white chick would say
wheelchair and then the guy would come
on in he'd be like sigue there with us
and we'd be like and then the cat and
then the oh how did I wear this [ __ ] in
class in high school would be like
they'll be like see ya the guy would say
see ya the ruthless and the class would
be like see they row we'd us and then
they would say Sica they're with us and
what what our class didn't realize and I
always realized I hated that they
[ __ ] class didn't pay attention to
this [ __ ] but they would you were only
supposed to say it after the first time
and then the guy would say it just to
remind you see ya they ruin us and then
it would go on to the next one it would
be like baseball and then you would have
to say baseball but everyone thought you
had to say the [ __ ] thing twice so it
will be like it would be like see ya
they ruin us and it would be like see
add a row eat us and then you would be
like see ya they ruin us and then
everyone be like see ya and they'd be
like baseball I don't really way later
Wyatt and I would always be like no you
only [ __ ] say it once you say it oh
no oh no oh oh no dawg wait why dude I
would laugh so hard at that [ __ ] I loved
it
see the rule see by the way how much is
that [ __ ] guy whoever did all those
audiobooks or textbook [ __ ] whatever
that guy just had on literally that you
know what that guy sounds like see
the ruthless who getting those baseball
that guy sounds like he walking straight
up got up in the morning put on a nice
button-down shirt [ __ ] no tie it's
open at the top because he's and then a
[ __ ] blazer and that's it no pants
are underwear and then shows up to work
and just [ __ ] in his blazer with
button-down shirt and the [ __ ] call
the the cuffs out and he just says see
Louie this and his dick is [ __ ]
medium-sized and he's in the recording
booth and he doesn't give a [ __ ] and
he's got a [ __ ] uh what'd he call my
tie
drinking a mai tai with flip-flops just
like see ya rule with us anyway what was
I [ __ ] talking about ISO so the racist
guys so so they're they're doing this
thing so they're doing this thing
they're talking about the [ __ ] what
do you call it
they're talking about the [ __ ] movies
and he says like you can tell this guy
just wants to be heard and just wants to
be like powerful so he says to the guy
who's black that's not with them and he
says hey man what do you do and the guy
said and the guy says I'm just a writer
or you know
act or whatever and the guy says oh yeah
are you funny and the guy says by the
way it's like it's like you can tell
racism is is on the way do you know what
I mean you can just tell that like uh
racism just got in the car and it's on
though it was like when you look at post
mates and it's like oh preparing the
order and that was where the racism was
and right when he said hey you funny
that was when it changed from preparing
to order and it says in wrote right
there and and so the guy says yeah I'm
funny and he says yeah
you do chocolate sundaes at the Laugh
Factory ah five minutes away no
ding-dong
[ __ ] straight up that's when it says
[ __ ] Abin is that your is is that
your is ready outside with your food
Abin is is he in his clothes go outside
that's the text you get from says you do
chocolate sundaes at the Laugh Factory
first of all those that you don't know
who chocolates what's chocolate sundaes
might be even though you definitely know
when I just say what it is it's
obviously the urban night at the Laugh
Factory and it's on Sunday so already
the guy's like he's black you do
chocolate so he's like he can't do a
normal night of comedy hey hey hey all
right and the guy says yeah the guy
actually [ __ ] throws racism on its
back and he says yeah yeah yeah I do it
I'm going actually I'm doing it this
week uh-uh so now the white guys like
see told you look white guys literally
thinking see girl the [ __ ] to say
like that's literally what he's thick
you know
and it's racist and so so he says so he
says she says are ya cool and he says
now what are we doing what are we doing
we got to check that out or whatever
like they're gonna go dude you know so
then he says hey do we have any it
literally says to his white people there
he says hey man do we have any movies
for black guys and that's when I just
looked over at him and I was like okay
well I'm not gonna pretend like I'm not
gonna understand what's happening so I
look and I and my jaw drops and I wait
to see how this you know cuz there's one
there's one guy there's just the one
black guy and there's five other people
so I'm like I'm like in this situation
where I'm like am I gonna am I gonna say
something here because like is it is it
the kind of thing where if post mates is
late am I gonna [ __ ] write a report
that's what I was that's where I was
like [ __ ] it's been an hour they
said they were gonna be here at 5:50
it's [ __ ] 6:15
do I contact post mates at this point or
do I see how post mates is going to deal
with this so I look at this it's so this
black guy cuz I cuz the guy if the guy
is like what the [ __ ]
then I'm gonna be like hey man yeah what
is yeah like if he if then if the white
guy is like oh well would I'll be like
bro you're being a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
cuz it was just us in the thing so now
but the black guy goes like this
hell yeah right one I'll do it so I'm
like okay well [ __ ] it that's how they
left it and then it was like 'yeah cuz i
think we're working with chris rock on
this thing and that which they're not of
course you know dude it was so it was so
i don't you know as a white guy who
lives where i live you don't see that
that much you see subtle [ __ ] you know
but to see that like [ __ ] so obvious
it was so uncomfortable you know i was
surprised that the guy didn't say
anything
i mean maybe he just deals with it so
much and [ __ ] like it's weird as a white
guy you don't really understand it you
don't really understand how much that
could possibly affect you all the time
over and over like I was I was working
out the other day this is another thing
kind of in the same vein I was working
out the other day and you know when
you're working out there's mirrors and
people like to look in the mirror when
they work out to make sure their forms
good or if they're just [ __ ] you know
a conceited you know guy or a girl that
just wants to see their body working out
because they think oh yeah I look good
now
I don't really care too much about the
mirror I mean like I'll go in front of
it if it's open and I'll work out but
it's not a big part of my thing like I
don't I'm not like I try to be a
bodybuilder and [ __ ] so I don't really
care what my muscles look like when I'm
working out and I also think my form is
fine you know I'm not trying to like be
like Oh arts a little more or [ __ ]
you know tense a little more at the top
like whatever I'm just [ __ ] throwing
weights around and doing
so there's this girl there I've talked
about her on the podcast before she
kills it she inspires she's inspiring
she's always [ __ ] killing it at the
gym and where that this gym where people
don't really work out all that hard
enough and because it's like a Hollywood
gym and she kills it though and so uh I
get in in the I get I'm doing these
squats and I'm looking in the mirror
doing the thing you know
and I noticed she's behind me and she
moves because I'm in the way and she
wants to see herself doing her [ __ ] and
I feel bad because I didn't she's by the
way she's way in the back I'd it's not
like I [ __ ] eat in and tried to get
in front of her I didn't realized that
she was doing that and so I was like oh
[ __ ] I feel bad like I didn't mean for
her to pick up and move her whole
workout right and so she did and I was
like I should [ __ ] I was like if I
get if she comes closer to me or if I
come closer again I'm gonna get like yo
sorry I mean do that so she so I walk by
her and I was like yo just so you know
like I didn't mean to get in your way
I'm so sorry about that
and she was like oh it's no problem like
all good and she was like so nice about
it I was like alright cool cool regular
[ __ ] whatever so then afterwards like
after a few minutes we were near in the
same area again and she said hey that
was just so you know that was like
really sweet that you said that and I
was like what and she was like I don't
know like being a girl like guys I knew
this is one not what you were doing but
guys get in the way of girls a lot
purposely because like I'm a woman and
either they think that you know they're
more important or whatever the [ __ ] and
I was like [ __ ] yeah I get it
that's so [ __ ] annoying and then I
was I was thinking about that and I was
talking to my girl afterwards and she
was like yeah that happens all the time
and like that's so annoying and I don't
know what it's like because I'm just a
[ __ ] white guy or a guy not even a
white guy at this in this situation but
I don't know you know talking about like
thinking about that like I have a little
bit of it because like you know if
people like I have people that know who
I am so like I was at the coffee bean
today and some guy came up as a gay man
you talked to me with this [ __ ] tuna
breath and [ __ ] oh my god okay cool
and that happens a lot but like it
hasn't happened since birth and women
have been dealing with that since
[ __ ] you know what I mean and that I
would be what I'm what I'm trying to say
is I would be the biggest [ __ ] ever
that's what I'm trying to say like I
would be the kind of girl where guys
would hate already because of the way I
walk is defensive do you know what I'm
talking about like I would be the kind
of girl that walks in a room doesn't
make eye contact with anybody and people
would be like stuck-up [ __ ] huh that's
me
and and a guy would come up and be like
excuse me and I'd be like yeah and he'd
be like whoa and I'd be like no what's
up and they'd be like another never mind
it's all good
and I'd be like and I wouldn't say [ __ ]
and then I just go back and drink my
[ __ ] smoothie or my earth bar [ __ ] or
eating my kale excuse me that would be
me excuse me get out of my way
emphasize my some [ __ ] old lady cut
me I get Beverly Hills
I got Beverly Hills degan man I talked
about this on the podcast I'm old lady
just cut me in line and I wanted to say
something but she was like also that age
where it was like she wasn't elderly but
she was like a little bit almost there
so I was like do I say something or what
she just [ __ ] snuck in she knows she
knows I got mad she [ __ ] Beverly
Hills me in Hollywood
anyway anyway people deal with their
people have their own [ __ ] to deal with
it and that that maybe that maybe that
guy that guy today was just like you
know what I don't want to deal with the
[ __ ] racism [ __ ] at this point
[ __ ] it maybe I'll get some work out of
it I don't want to make it uncomfortable
I deal with this [ __ ] all the time [ __ ]
it maybe maybe not uh maybe he was maybe
he didn't know IKEA had to have known
had to have his own okay so I'm gonna do
my errands here
speaking of which posts mates since we
talked about it but listen I use it all
the time as usual your stomach and the
rest of your life rat war you need to
eat but you can't stop what you're doing
to deal with it because you're
professional you're an adult you don't
have time to go drive to lunch and then
eat and then come back the fast things
that deliver are not usually what you
want okay well not anymore
post mates the app that adds a delivery
option to your favorite restaurants
imagine anything you want to eat
delivered anything any of your
restaurants your favorite restaurants
you don't have to drive park or even
talk on the phone to order you don't
have to do that just download the app
and order 24 hours a day 365 days a year
post mice will bring you what you want
within the hour
you can see where your food is in track
it track the driver you forget eggs and
milk it doesn't matter no problem you
want a burger
get it you look for them you looking for
the perfect bottle of red wine or a
summer beer you just order up man you
can do it get stuff at like 7-eleven
anywhere postmates says your new
long-term munchies booty call and I
didn't write that part for a limited
time post mates is giving you $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app today and use code
Congrats that's code congrats for $100
of free delivery credit for your first 7
days save the hassle get the food you
love fast at post mates with code
Congrats if you guys aren't using post
mates what are you doing really I use it
every day trip actions
there's a reason half of business
travelers do not use their company's
chosen travel management platform
booking business travel is still
ridiculously outdated time consuming and
costly if you're frustrated with your
company's travel management program or
lack thereof you need to look into trip
actions
they take the pain out of corporate
travel with a complete solution that
helps business save and keeps employees
happy the reason trip Actions works so
well is that it's the first travel
management platform designed from the
ground up with the road warrior in mind
I'm a road warrior it's easy to book
your company's business travel from the
app or desktop with 24/7 proactive
support around the globe and incentives
for employees to save on travel expenses
companies large and small see over 90%
adoption and save up to 34% on travel
spend when they use trip actions yay
lift - Sara Lee's frozen bakery trust
trip actions with their business travel
so you should do reshape your company's
business travel today with trip actions
go to trip actions dot-com / Congrats
complete a 30-minute demo with a trip
actions Account Executive and you'll get
$100 Amazon gift card but it's this
month only trip actions dot-com /
congrats for a free demo and $100 Amazon
gift card trip actions dot-com /
Congrats trip actions dot-com / Congrats
trip actions dot-com / congrats for a
free demo and $100 Amazon gift card
there you go you want that Amazon gift
card babies say yeah that's what's up I
got oh by the way I got off hey how
about this man I got a [ __ ] tetanus
shot I haven't gotten to checkup in 17
years a doctor's appointment to check up
in 17 [ __ ] years and I went and I
didn't want to and I did because I'm
healthy and I'm fine and I went he was
like basically all they do is like
alright let me check your heart rate and
all this I had nothing wrong with me in
17 years back pain whatever everyone's
got back pain they were like well he was
like might as well give you
tetanus shot and I was like all right
cool they give it to me dude hey I got
it Wednesday I'm still [ __ ] man it
hurts a lot
now I'm not [ __ ] dude I'm a ha I'm hard
my [ __ ] I maybe I'm a [ __ ] man this
[ __ ] hurt I need a [ __ ] see ya they
rule with us see a day row eat us see
the rule bus
see ya dairy I need it no no wait oh
wait I need a [ __ ] it hurts dude my
[ __ ] hurts bro
it's [ __ ] five six days and I can't I
got I can't do this [ __ ] I mean I can do
it but oh [ __ ] it's that movement that
hurts a lot right there it's [ __ ]
nurse just jab me with it felt like it
went in my [ __ ] tendon that sucks you
know I'm never gonna get tetanus I'm
never even outdoors what I'm gonna run
rub up against a rusty nail where I live
in Hollywood where the [ __ ] got that
gonna happen it was like you gotta get
your tetanus shot no you don't and then
he was like trying to sucker me into
getting a [ __ ] flu shot I don't need
to get that [ __ ] man do you know he was
saying he was like every 10 to 15 years
there's a flu shot there's a flu there's
a strain of flu that's like a epidemic
or a pandemic or whatever the [ __ ] some
kind of Demick and he said but every
year it's bad but he's like you want to
get the shot on that one because if you
get down one you're on your back for
like [ __ ] two weeks it's like 10 to
15 years every 10 to 15 years and flu
shots are a guess by the way they don't
know what strain is gonna be the
outbreak this year if there is one if
there is one so there you're getting a
flu shot you might get sick from it you
ever see that [ __ ] video where the
girl got the blue flu shot and then now
all she can do is walk backwards ah she
walks backwards bro walk in front words
forget about it that's what she that's
what forget it
she got a flu shot I swear to God I saw
this it was on the news I was a kid she
got a flu shot and now she can only walk
backwards she cannot walk forwards hey
man
that's hell I'd rather be in a [ __ ]
sea little with us this is the one one
fire is but she can walk backward yeah
she can walk backwards dude she can't
walk forward I saw that and I was like
well never getting a flu shot
that's just so [ __ ] up that it [ __ ]
her up like that I know that's a rare
case look at look at the look at the
thing that he's looking up on YouTube
woman takes flu vaccine now she can't
walk forward I mean bro it's actually
the most horrific thing I ever saw when
I was a kid I was like well never get a
flu shot
I'll get the flu [ __ ] that'll be on my
back for two days poor girl man just to
walk backwards upstairs and [ __ ] I
thought everything looks like it's
rewind and she was she's like this
[ __ ] regular you know pretty good
young girl is that her I don't know
they're interviewing people like they
can say anything like yes she used to
walk forward and now she can only walk
backwards after getting a flu shot poor
girl man I mean I was definitely a freak
thing but oh she's better now
oh she's better now ah she's better now
that's really sweet look at look at look
at go down go down to go to go down look
at that right there
oh look at this guy oh it's ohcome on
it's convenient her symptoms only occur
when she knows she's being watched
dude there's so many [ __ ] offices in
this podcast the other day as soon as
some [ __ ] happens they think that nobody
I think was sword in scale as soon as
some [ __ ] happens like the Orlando
shooting there's people that are like
yeah well it's the government they think
they're making this happen cuz they're
trying to take our guns away
they don't think Sandy Hook happened
like people are [ __ ] live-tweeting
they're like the government just hired
people to live tweet a [ __ ] event
huh dude it's so insane what people
think anyway I got my tetanus shot don't
get your [ __ ] tetanus shot there's no
reason to you're not gonna rust hold a
rusty crowbar like what are you in
Double Dragon dude what are you in
[ __ ] double dragon
what are you in [ __ ] what was a
double dragon song dude I love this
podcast
you guys are awesome man you guys are so
fun double dragon theme song we talked
about theme songs last night what are
you what are you building a basic Wow
play this at my funeral for real when
they bring out when they bring me out
dude all I want to do is talk about old
video game songs I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't even like I don't even like video
games dude so victorious is the most
Japanese thing I ever heard in my life I
like what goes faster though so
repetitive
dude I [ __ ] was that why did I bring
up double dragon all rusty crowbars dude
my I'm all over the place
promise to be all over the place no
matter what my babies yeah dude this
[ __ ] cult is strong it doesn't matter
we go all over the place but yeah so I
got my tetanus shot and it's not worth
it I mean I don't know and now now if
some of your baby's gonna be like I'm
not going to turn this shot and they're
gonna rub up against a rusty nail I pick
up an old crop program crowbar to make a
joke about the podcast that you heard on
Double Dragon and now you gonna get
tetanus because of the podcast and I'm
[ __ ]
I told you not to get a tetanus shot
well you know what I have to say to that
guys fellas you know I have to say to
that great my phone's not opening one
fire even though it's not his fault
that's why I have to say to that I love
how it stops
so anyway dude by the way in the video
game Double Dragon how about the fact
that like there were bad chicks and the
guy just like you were just the lead guy
and you just beat the [ __ ] out of chicks
try and subdue him stop punching purple
haired chicks with blue jumpsuits in the
face I guess I wonder what video games
were like did you hear about that guy on
the the guy on the I saw it on that
barstool sports Instagram where he was
like yeah it got me thinking actually
because the guy is like a big popular
gamer and he like surprised the fan by
what do you call it by by saying I was
he was gonna play with him and then he
was like here here's the thing and the
mom came on and was like oh where it
says she went full To Catch a Predator
on him like she was like it we wanted to
talk to him because here I'll just play
it for you guys here trigger
[Applause]
[Music]
playing for tonight hey listen they
watch my videos I joined in to Surprise
them and then next thing you know you
know and then now we're here playing and
they usually surprise boys these days if
you don't understand you know what the
scenario is well my son is very happy
that you are playing with him but I like
to know I mean the guy was like first of
all I suppose it's a normal thing I
don't know I don't know how old the kid
is but this guy known twitch streamer
jack optic courage Dunlop change it
optic courage know what that means no
courage um yeah you know he looks like
he's 30 or something it might be older I
mean I'm sure the guy's nice enough you
know I mean obviously he's not trying to
[ __ ] be I mean obviously he's this is
how it is he wanted to surprise a fan
and this fan happened to be younger and
who gives a [ __ ] but then I got to
thinking like it is kind of creepy
though you know like if a guy that a 30
something year old guy can just play a
video game with a [ __ ] nine year old
you know that's just kind of creepy and
I know yes one fire-type just type to me
but it's over the Internet
yeah creepier you know I don't know
something creepier about that like him
personally said like yeah I'm just
playing I have [ __ ] but over the
Internet you're like you know it's just
weird
I know it's over the Internet and he's
just surprised them and [ __ ] but it's
just like it was so funny too cuz this
guy's obviously a good guy he's
obviously not doing
things shady I don't think but like but
like the way he responds his book is
like oh wait oh no I do realize that
it's very weird you know look he's
laughing because he knows on transcript
Adam cinema was like today jr. yeah he
could he could he could leave if he did
if you don't understand this is an area
dude that that was so funny because like
it was so like a mom that doesn't get it
that doesn't get what this [ __ ] is but
like it's also is kind of creepy that a
thirtysomething and you're basically
talking on the phone to a [ __ ]
eight-year-old and yeah he's a fan and
yeah you're not gonna do anything but
it's still it's still creepy I mean if I
had kids I wouldn't want my
eight-year-old kid playing a video game
with a 30 year old somewhere in like
Wisconsin or anywhere you know my videos
and gaming game in some fortnight I
means you have four hundred twenty eight
thousand followers you just trying to
surprise the kid in the moms like hello
excuse me you're a creepy [ __ ] yeah I
mean it sounds like a CD skipping
there's an if you don't you mean he
doesn't have that yeah
he doesn't have to they watch my videos
and I just came and I they watch my
videos and I just wanted to surprise him
and next-step prison so [ __ ] so
[ __ ] creepy it sound like a [ __ ]
Daniel Bedingfield song it one more time
got me feeling so free I mean dude
listen they Digital by blue I'm I mean I
am I'm working how does he stutter that
much that's the new that that's
unbelievable dude oh that's so good I
mean that [ __ ] is so good that's
basically what happened that's what
that's the beginning of that song to me
that's like [ __ ] house music song good
good with kids this age that's the bomb
[Music]
right here oh man how funny is it that
you can just get like [ __ ] accused
[ __ ] you know like that like like this
I'm sure this guy's a good guy he seems
like he's just [ __ ] didn't think
about and it was just [ __ ] playing
video games and he's just like got his
[ __ ] together and he's just got it he's
just a [ __ ] streamer you know not a
[ __ ] perv
or a pedophile and now
people are just gonna because this came
on the air or on the air because this is
now going viral he's gonna have this
[ __ ] annoying [ __ ] that he's
gonna follow up well I I don't know he
just got this annoying [ __ ] now it's
like the [ __ ] guys that think sandy
hooks a [ __ ] lie it's like it's just
somebody said it and now it's a thing
that's so annoying dude oh man I stand
with whatever the [ __ ] this guy's name
is optic [ __ ] courage I stand with
optic courage he wasn't trying to perv
[ __ ] that's funny to me huh [ __ ] that's
funny to me man
all right cool here we go mm-hmm hims
look I'm gonna be real with you guys
okay straight up 66% of men lose their
hair by age 35 now I'm not trying to bat
brag boast or gloat but I made it okay
the thing is when you start to notice
hair loss it's too late that's it see
you later guys bye hair we you're
retreating see you later
it's running away it's easier to keep
the hair you have then to replace the
hair you've lost now that's what people
don't get people think that oh when I
start going bald I'll start taking
treatment no you gotta do it to keep
make sure he's I hear you have stays is
that a hair line of yours is it slowly
retreating is it slowly starting to move
backwards do you have any bald spots yet
uh-oh how are you gonna feel a year from
now if it's if it's if it's business as
usual up there what are you gonna do
look do you want a bald spot to pop up
or do you want to do something about it
first you want your hairline to recede
or you want to do something about it
first why do guys turn into weird
solutions or do nothing when they can
turn to medicine and science for hims
calm a one-stop shop for hair loss skin
care sexual wellness for men thanks to
science baldness can be optional hims
connects you with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat hair
loss you know generic well known generic
equivalents to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
there's no snake oil pill
or gas station counter supplements all
that stuff's you know it's crap there's
no waiting room no awkward in-person
doctor visits save hours by going to
four hams calm it's easy answer few
quick questions and a doctor will review
and prescribe you shipped directly to
your door order now my listeners get a
trial month of hymns for just $5 today
right now while supplies last see
website for full details this would cost
hundreds if you went to the doctor or a
pharmacy go to for hymns calm / Congrats
that's fo rh IMS calm / congrats for
hymns calm / Congrats the zebra it has
been reported that Americans are
overpaying on car insurance by overt
check this out 21 billion dollars but
searching for a better deal can take
hours and typically results in a barrage
of unwanted spam calls until now thanks
to the zebra comm the zebra comm is the
nation's leading car insurance
comparison site because it's the only
place you can compare hundreds of
policies from all the top carriers and
choose the best for you plus they will
never sell your information to spammers
which is important mmm
you won't get all those unwanted calls
or emails TechCrunch said it's the best
the zebra is like kayak for auto
insurance this is definitely one of
those things that should have existed
before and it's it's a great service so
this is how buying car insurance should
be and you know they finally figured it
out so are you comparing insurance
before you buy
are you not comparing insurance before
you buy huh cheedo go today and start
saving at the zebra dot-com / Congrats
that's the zebra dot-com / Congrats
spelled th e ze br a.com / congrats you
already know the cash app is the number
one finance app for the App Store what
you might not know is that you can also
put cash up in your wallet we
the cash card it's the only debit card
that offers instant rewards and comes
packed with premium features not even a
credit card can offer like boost save up
to 10% instantly at Whole Foods Wendy's
our Chipotle or more your favorite spots
even $1 off coffee every time you swipe
a cash card at coffee shops across the
country the cash card puts you in
control of your money with extra in-app
safety features that let you pause your
card with the touch there's no fees
unlike a credit card and a credit check
isn't required to get one download the
cash app now and get your cash card free
visit the App Store or Google Play
market now and of course when you
download the cash app and enter a
referral code Congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 - times up Legal Defense Fund a
true win-win right and whenever you use
the cash our is basically now we got to
back up the Brinks truck or the woman's
truck I just want to make one song just
one song that's just [ __ ] killing it
and then just sing it forever Daniel
Bedingfield this [ __ ] didn't she have
that Natasha Bedingfield sister yeah
that what was that song she had Natasha
bit on your feet no no no no no she was
that song right you know no what was
that [ __ ] unwritten got it without
the use of Google my babies
what was I gonna say oh yes so I was at
my checkup
and dude the doctor looks at me and says
well the only thing I could find wrong
with you is that you have a lot of
earwax in your right ear okay and I said
really
he said yeah so what's the deal he said
it's basically clogged all the way I
said yeah I said he's affected my
hearing he said maybe in the right ear
I said whoa he's like well here's what
we got to do we either got to try to
take it out now or if it hurts to try
and take it out with this and shows up a
[ __ ] something that like the guy from
saw would use to torture somebody or we
go and we
soften it up with liquid and then we
[ __ ] wait a little bit and then
soften it up with some saline solution
and then it [ __ ] pours out and I was
like alright well let's just try the the
[ __ ] og way man saw it up I want to
play a game you've been living with
earwax for way too long
you cannot hear out of the right side of
your head let's see what it would be
like to take this steel rod and inject
it into your brain you must fight to
survive try not to lean to the right it
will go directly through your brain
fight to survive ever so I'm like
alright just use that and he's like all
right here we go and he does it and I go
like this when he puts it in my ear I go
like this ah because it felt like two
penguins were [ __ ] in my head okay oh
it hurt oh it hurt and made a tetanus
feel made a tetanus shot feel like I was
getting a massage alright so I was like
he said does it hurt and I said yep he
said okay let's try to squash it out so
then he is like took this though the
squeezy bottle thing way too big by the
way he brought it up it was like yet the
[ __ ] backup a truck to get it in put
it in my ear and it was like is it loud
he was like might be a little loud
squeeze it in my ear this is what it
sounded like he disclosed it in my ear
it was so loud dude do you know what
it's like to have something squeezed in
your ear and I was like oh my god it's
so loud he was like yeah well I thought
it might be and then I was like Jesus
Christ was like able just let it sit
there and then [ __ ] in 20 minutes
we'll put the saline solution 20 minutes
went by put the saline solution in they
put a [ __ ] thing here like a pan here
to catch all I'm like what is this for
it's like to catch all the liquid and
the earwax I'm like how much do I have
in there so then she squeezed the
[ __ ] saline
that was even louder bro and then I
looked in the pan and it looked like
[ __ ] something that would be in like
a an Arby's trashcan where you'd be like
what the [ __ ] is that dude it was so
gross and the rest of the day it was
coming out dude it was so gross
you gotta get thin as an earwax and now
by the way I was tricking myself all day
like I think I could hear better but I
don't know if I could but now it feels
fine I never I didn't notice though it
built up over time and I was like what
will it come out eventually he was like
no that's [ __ ] crazy right you just
get here waxing them what if what if in
1600 you had your wax that's it you're
not getting it out you got to go to a
witch or some [ __ ] dude I love that
people in the world just travel on
Instagram and they think that because
they're traveling that they're brave and
they tell other people to just stop just
do it you know just do it throw caution
to the wind
take that [ __ ] thing today book the
trip now you're not being inspirational
you didn't do any you're just going some
dude like like oh wow you have such
courage because you went to Greece dude
it's not [ __ ] 1412
we already know the places exist you got
courage going to plate going to the
unknown you know you don't have courage
because you [ __ ] took a week off of
work and went to the [ __ ] mall dives
you [ __ ] a hooker you can only do
that if you're a hooker anyway you're
rich so ridiculous
I sent one of those instagrams to my
buddy and he was like he was like I went
all in and then my buddy was like -
Betty didn't go all in on spelling like
that's the other thing which is
hilarious cuz it's like it's like dude
these guys are idiots you know this guy
just wearing khaki shorts of course real
tight with a [ __ ] button-down just
walking on a boardwalk somewhere and he
was like do it now like do what now
you're not [ __ ] courageous you idiot
you're walking around and someone's
shooting you
everybody's a goddamn model now that's
the [ __ ] problem all these chicks
think they're gonna be more famous than
you you know in Hollywood
instagrams [ __ ] - the game up man never
went [ __ ] guys like Tony Danza Tony
Danza would just [ __ ] scoop it up you
kidding me Tony dancer would be like it
was a good one you want some [ __ ] and
they'd be like cher I'm never gonna meet
another famous guy great scoop that up
Berber and then he's out
oh [ __ ] you real good barber catch you
later
now now bro now if 20 dancer was famous
now he wouldn't berber ever bro
if Tony Danza was famous now dude you
got to be [ __ ] John Mayer you got to
be [ __ ] you got to be a Matt Damon
bro you got to be Hugh Jackman you got
to be huge Ackman you gotta be [ __ ]
dude ah Hugh Jackman whatever I'm living
large this guy bought me a coffee today
because he was a fan so that's it dude
I'm living [ __ ] large guy goes like
this this guy I walk in the coffee shop
he says this guy and I go oh no and he
comes up and he's so big and Scottish
and you
like man I gotta get you a coffee nose
like I you don't have to he's like sure
no let's do it and I did him and I had
talked him for a while he bought my time
like it was a [ __ ] public lap dance
that's basically what it is when
somebody when you're a [ __ ] guy when
you're a famous guy and somebody buys
you coffee that's a public lap dance
he's giving you're giving you got to
give him cuz now you got to talk to him
while the coffee's getting ready
that was nice enough was he in the
[ __ ] tuna sandwich while he was
talking to me yeah did it bug me
yeah because did it smoke too much like
tuna yeah and did he know that before I
went to go get my coffee I was thinking
oh I can't wait to get home so I could
make some tuna and that he ruined my
idea of eating tuna after the coffee did
he know that no he didn't know that does
that make it less frustrating no but
this is my life and my life is hard you
know I wanted to eat tuna uninterrupted
with tuna smell and he ruined it and he
bought me a coffee and I had to give him
a public lap dance a public
conversational lap dance is what I had
to give him that's what it is and when
you're famous guy you just got to deal
with it now yeah I granted but still now
yeah granted but still it was sweet of
him he was a [ __ ] nice guy thank you
very much
and I got fans in Scotland my babies
well I go know people like when you come
to the [ __ ] people will be like when
you come and have [ __ ] when you come
into uh Antarctica
you've got babies down here oh really
I'm gonna do a [ __ ] show with four
people we're all anything I could see
are their [ __ ] face and like this cuz
they have a [ __ ] Kenny yet jacket on
and then [ __ ] 75 penguins they can't
even clap can they they can't even reach
[ __ ] ass golf clapping
conversationalist conversational
lapdance public conversational lap dance
sometimes we [ __ ] come up with the
names while we're doing it we always do
that's what you know what dude all right
listed some quit maybe we go to Twitter
questions dude that's so funny to me
[Music]
what do you think of Adam Sandler
getting back in a stand-up
congratulations part Randle current Rio
ah do you have the ruthless Randall
coentrão ad say underscore Portuguese
change it so I think it's great
I [ __ ] love Adam Sandler man I think
that what what he does is awesome he
makes movies and he employs a lot of his
friends and he's really good to people
he's really nice I hear I've never met
him but and I heard his uh Netflix thing
is hilarious and really good a lot of
people I respect I said it's really good
I've haven't seen it yet I have yet to
see it but I hear it's great people I
respect said he's awesome so I can't
wait to see it yeah I think I think Adam
centers awesome I [ __ ] love Adam
Sandler
okay so here's something that we that I
was wondering about actually this is
from coda at D Campbell cw17 change it
hey crystal how do you feel about No
Shave well okay so no shave there's a
double part question no-shave November
Movember right that's for cancer right
never proposed it for like prostate
cancer you shave to awareness whatever
fine you know some of the awarenesses
are getting weird and [ __ ] it's like
yeah I got a [ __ ] I put a dildo hat
on my forehead for [ __ ] three weeks
to four you know four foot for [ __ ]
psoriasis and you're like okay so now I
know what it is what the [ __ ] do I do
now I don't know donate or something
find a link see ya and they walk away
under dildo hat so that's cool though I
guess awareness for cancer is good just
cancer is the [ __ ] biggest problem in
the goddamn
old known that this is something I heard
of just this year no nut November which
first of all is not even a clever name
how about like something clever you know
no not November who also who uses the
word nut to talk about an orgasm like
that's so gangster to say yo I'm not a
dog
you are not it on her yo you know inside
her hell yeah I'm not insider you trying
to get babies yeah no but that [ __ ] feel
too good dog
no nut no what's that mean you're just
not supposed to [ __ ] have an orgasm
all of November for what for what hey
pick ax if it's for awareness for
something pick a different thing
also you can lie about that you can't
lie about and have it a mustache did you
not know really yeah
it's November 6 did you not yet well uh
no of course not really yeah
what were you doing in your bedroom till
10:00 a.m. uh no nut November is the
biggest crock of [ __ ] I've ever heard in
my life you know what I'm coming more in
November how about that just because of
no not November I'm bussing everywhere
I'm busting at the supermarket I'm
walking into [ __ ] var just like I'm
walking into [ __ ] Ralph or shop right
with Tony Danza like burger bar dude
Daniel Bedingfield Wow
I didn't realize you looked like this
couldn't look more like a guy that says
like that's such a dick that says like
[ __ ] you in church he looks like Perez
Hilton put the mask on
and he's just like smokin Perez Hilton
put the mask on and then smoke in ah man
uh okay anyway
damn dude him and Etosha better feel
good to have some deep family secrets
they couldn't look like they have some
deep family secrets uh Chris Thalia have
you ever used your jujitsu training
outside of the dojo now mm just mentally
I think though that the confidence of I
be injured a long time I would get my
[ __ ] ass kicked now from anybody who
took four days of classes but I think
the confidence of having took it I just
feel like people kind of like there's
that whole unsaid kind of like thought
where like they pick up you pick up on
[ __ ] I think that you can I don't know I
always say that fights happen only
happen if the two people fighting want
it to happen you know I mean there's of
course things that happen that you're
you know there's exceptions to the rules
and [ __ ] but like dude if somebody
really wants to fight me I don't want to
fight like I'm like wait for what like
just relax guy you know and it's not
gonna happen but if - if I'm like oh
yeah well [ __ ] you then the fights gonna
happen you know and then I [ __ ] but
uh ya know so I haven't used it
unless I've used it mentally because I'm
like I know now I know not I know not
nothing about fighting so maybe I've
gotten out of it because somebody could
like sense that on said [ __ ] about it
anyway is there any more it's cool my
tetanus shot keep certain more and more
okay this is a good one
Christopher Lovgren Jesus of course the
crystal were spelled with an F there's
nothing that's the most foreign name of
all time is Christopher spelled with an
F there but not a pH that's like them
that's more foreign
the name like [ __ ] ker plot or also
eben I said it early in a podcast but
like Evan is s foreign when you change
one letter in a regular American name
that guy is from Pluto I don't give a
[ __ ] Steven you know
do you watch scary movies through your
fingers when shits about to happen or
watch it all straight up I mean first of
all I'll watch it all straight up you
know so far an at reach Christopher with
an F um you know see today I've changed
it but see it but hello because you're
welcome here at the log cabin
there's no I I watch I sometimes a movie
so scary I won't like slink in my seat
but I will like look off center of the
screen because I'm like what's gonna
happen I gotta [ __ ] see it out of my
peripheral and not look at it straight
on I definitely have done that the movie
that's the scariest is I've taught I've
told you here before it's called pulse
I've done that that's the one movie
that's made me slink in my [ __ ] seat
and pull my blanket up almost over my
eyes
that it was the scariest that has made
me do that maybe one or two other movies
but that movie was me I think maybe the
only movie to make me actually do it
that much so yeah that's it anyway but
and then when I did it
yeah dude hey listen it's 2019 coming up
and well before I said that actually
download the cash app for free on the
App Store or Google Play market and to
reward code Congrats get $5 and give $5
- times up and by the way guys also go
vote huh if you're a baby you got to go
vote go vote for your for your [ __ ] man
the more people that vote the better
this is America
subscribe to the YouTube channel the
store is coming down for maintenance
tomorrow for about a week so sorry if
you want to go buy your shirts go buy
them right now the make good Christmas
gifts as you know because any gift makes
a good Christmas gift and even though
people say that when they're trying to
push their product and it makes good
sense and it resonates to people
so listen it's 2019 here's another thing
that makes good Christmas gifts and this
is not going down for six days for about
a week follow the leader new dates for
2019 on sale now they just went on sale
now they're getting pushed Chicago sold
out really quickly I mean you guys they
were gonna sell out Boulder Colorado
sold out a lot of these places sold out
so go get your tickets now because yeah
it's months before but you're not gonna
be able to come to the cult meetings and
you're not gonna be able to come see me
and you know look they're gonna sell out
regardless I want you to come so I want
the people who want to be there the most
to be there so the people who want to be
there the most other people get the
tickets the earliest so just if you want
to be one of those people then go do it
and go do it now
Louisville Kentucky Indian Indianapolis
which is how I say Indianapolis
Indianapolis st. Louis Missouri Boulder
Colorado Springs Colorado
Salt Lake City Madison Milwaukee Chicago
Seattle Hamilton Windsor Kalamazoo
Kalamazoo Anaheim Santa Ynez Valley
Center Albany Hanover Huntington
Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati Lexington
for some reason Albuquerque for some
reason Santa Fe Phoenix Tucson
Greensboro for some reason North
Carolina Charlotte Durham North Carolina
Newport News Virginia for some reason
Oakland and Las Vegas Nevada
Oh coming up Miami West Palm Beach
Jacksonville Atlanta Los Angeles San
Francisco Boston Fresno Bakersfield
Austin and San Antonio now
crazy amounts of kitchen I mean but uh
you know we got to do it cuz we got to
get the word out there subscribe and
rate review the show please that really
helps and Wow is that yours
somebody made a Visa debit card from
from the cash out and made it [ __ ] and
say do we have that on here or no it
says a little problem it is thanks a lot
you guys having a good time have a good
week my babies see in Florida and
Atlanta
[Music]